hello i hope everyone is doing well
today we are about to get started
uh we're very excited to have brad
larson principal scientist here at
biotech
give today's presentation on automated
media exchange for
long-term spheroid assays using multiflo
fx's new amx module we will be fielding
questions at the end of the webinar
so if you have any questions during the
presentation please submit them with the
chat feature
we will also be emailing a recording of
today's event to all registrants
so thank you for joining us and with
that i will pass it over to brad
okay thank you dylan uh hello everyone
as dylan just mentioned i'm brad larson
a principal scientist in the
applications group
here at biotech i'd also like to welcome
each of you and thank you for joining
our webinar today
what i'm going to be talking about over
the next hour is
introducing you to a new tool that
biotech has developed
to enable media exchanges and washing of
unattached 3d cell models
the tool is dylan just mentioned is
called the amx or automated media
exchange module
and works with the multiflo fx as you
see here
in the picture
if we take a quick look at what i'm
going to be covering in the webinar i'll
begin by first taking a few minutes to
talk about why 3d cell culture is
important
to so many areas of research today i'm
also going to
take a bit of time to either introduce
for some review or re-familiarize for
the rest of you
the instrument that the module works
with which is biotech's multiflo effects
dispenser
and microplate washer then i'll explain
how the amx module works and how it
enables robust aspiration and dispense
of media or wash and fixative components
without removing spheroids from
microplate wells
then finally we'll look at both
qualitative and quantitative validation
of the module
using a variety of cell models and
microplates from a variety of vendors
in 96 or 384 well format
so to begin with if we go back to 2011
out of approximately 900 anti-cancer
therapies in clinical trials
or under fda review only 12 achieved
approval
resulting in a loss of hundreds of
millions of dollars that were spent on
pre-clinical and clinical trials
the reason for these shortfalls was
traced to using conventional 2d cell
culture conditions
and as you can see in the model shown on
the slide
mimiking and in vivo three-dimensional
tumor you see
extracellular matrix or ecm components
and cell cell and cell to matrix
interactions
important for differentiation
proliferation and cellular functions
and when cells are cultured in 2d ecm
as well as signaling patterns seen in
vivo are lost
parallel research has also indicated
that
traditional 2d cell culture methods do
not allow for areas of hypoxia
heterogeneous cell populations including
stromal cells
varying cell proliferation zones such as
quiescent
and replicating ecm influences
soluble signal gradients and
differential nutrient
and metabolic waste transport and as a
result this unnatural 2d environment
may provide inaccurate data regarding
the
predicted response of cancer cells to
chemotherapeutics
many of the same concerns with using 2d
cell culture
to create accurate tumor models also
extend to non-disease
organ models including liver models
which we're seeing data
for here incorporating primary
hepatocyte cultures
provides levels of functionality closer
to that seen in vivo but even these
cells
are problematic when used in vitro under
traditional 2d cell culture conditions
so here as you can see by looking at the
green orange and red lines
2d cultured cells differentiate and
rapidly
decrease expression of cytochrome p450
enzymes
and eventually lose viability
hepatocytes cultured
into 3d hepatospheres in contrast
maintain high expression of cytochrome
p450 enzymes over multi-week
incubation periods used in this study
additional studies have also cultured 3d
hepatospheres for greater than
one month with no loss of expression or
viability
this then as we all know has led to a
dramatic increase in the incorporation
of 3d cell models for a variety of
research areas
such as oncology toxicology and in
in addition to environmental and
cosmetic testing
one of the most widely used methods to
culture cells
in 3d today is to place the cells into a
round or pyramid bottom type of well
coated with a surface which does not
allow for cell attachment
and then allow the cells to aggregate at
the bottom of the well
this method is relatively easy to
optimize and also allows
aggregation and assay performance in the
same well which is a great advantage
however if the cells need to be cultured
for long periods of time
making media exchanges a necessity or if
the assay procedure is non-homogeneous
requiring washes to remove reagents or
unincorporated dyes or probes
this can make for a tedious and very
stressful process
normally to perform these steps a manual
single or multi-channel pipette is used
and liquid
is removed from the wells as slowly as
possible
but even when a great deal of care is
taken to evacuate
the wells in a slow manner steroids many
times are still removed
and as you can see from the visceral
visual results of the media exchange
performed here this is indeed the case
dispense steps can also pose a problem
if the dispense speed is too high
spheroids can be pushed off the bottom
of the well up into the media
then if a second aspiration step is
performed the spheroid is easily removed
from the well
or even for single aspiration and
dispense media exchange cycles
with a high rate of dispense the
spheroid can be pushed
out of the field of view when performing
imaging applications
and eliminating the data from that well
from any analysis
of course large liquid handling systems
can be used to perform media exchanges
or washes
but the size of these instruments
creates the need for large
very expensive containment systems in
order to avoid contamination when used
so to solve these multiple complications
and make 3d assay procedures easier to
perform
biotech has developed an automated media
exchange or amx
module specialized to perform single
media exchanges or multiple plate washes
in a slow controlled manner that allows
liquid to be aspirated
from the wells of a spheroid microplate
and then dispense back liquid without
removing or disturbing the spheroids
the module works on biotech's multiflo
fx dispenser as you can see here
and i'll explain more about the
particular components of the module
and its operation in a couple slides
but before i do as i mentioned earlier
i'd like to first go over the
capabilities
of the multiflo fx for those of you not
familiar with the instrument the
multiflo fx provides the ability to
perform parallel non-contact dispensing
in a wide variety of microplates up to
1536 well format
using either peristaltic pumps or
syringes
a second arm can also be outfitted with
either a wash module
to allow for column wise washing our rad
module which enables random access
dispensing into individual wells
and now the aspirate portion of the amx
module
the instrument itself has a very small
footprint allowing it to be easily
placed into laminar flow hoods
which eliminates the need for purchasing
a second contain a separate containment
system
which as mentioned before is necessary
for large liquid handling systems
the instrument is also modular and
upgradable meaning
that you can start with a single module
such as a single peristaltic pump or
serene
or syringe dispensing and then add on
more capabilities at a later date
for use with the amx module specifically
as you can see in the picture a primary
and secondary peristaltic pump is
required in addition to the secondary
arm
so now if we take a closer look at the
amx module itself we can see that the
physical components
consist of two peristaltic pump
cassettes which you see on the left
and two newly designed cassette heads
which contain a set of eight
stainless steel tubes which you see on
the right the cassettes are the same
five microliter cassettes that would be
used to perform non-contact dispensing
and other procedures
and the top end of the tube which you
see with the the black
cassette heads on the right again that
extend up out of the top of the head
connect directly to the end of the
cassette tubing
the cassettes and heads are completely
autoclavable which
makes them easy to sterilize before use
when setting up the module to perform
spheroid media exchanges or watches the
cassettes are added in the following
manner to the fx
the aspirate cassette is fed through the
secondary peristaltic pump is indicated
by the blue arrow
and again this is the same as
peristaltic pump
setup when performing non-contact
dispensing
then the head is attached to the
secondary accessory
arm as indicated by the blue arrow on
the right
the other end of the cassette tubing is
placed into a container holding an
appropriate
liquid that will be used to prime the
cassette prior to aspiration
and to hold all liquid removing removed
from the microplate wells
priming with the liquid allows for
consistent aspiration across all
channels in the cassette
similar to the use of a system fluid in
other liquid handling systems
the dispense cassette is added to the fx
in the same manner so here
the cassette tubing is fed through the
primary peristaltic pump again as
indicated by the blue arrow
then the head of this cassette is
attached to the primary arm
the other end of this cassette can then
be added to a container holding fresh
media
wash components or since each line of
the cassette is attached to a single
dispense tube
the eight individual lines can be added
to individual tubes containing different
concentrations
of a test molecule for automated
dispensing of a titration series
once the cassettes are fully added to
the multi-floor effects if we
look at the picture in this slide you
can get a better
idea of the placement of the two amx
module heads
the aspirate has again is attached to
the secondary arm
and is seen to the right and higher up
in the x-axis in the picture the
dispense head
is attached to the primary arm to the
left and further down in the x-axis
in the picture the advantage of this
configuration
is that the two heads can now move
independently of each other
meaning that while either aspirate or
dispense steps are being performed
the head not in use is automatically
moved up in the x-axis to avoid hitting
the microplate
the fine motor control in the z-axis for
both arms
also allows for a more accurate
optimization of
the aspiration and dispense procedures
specific for the type and
well configuration of the included
plates
in addition to the hardware components
i've been speaking to you about
new base code and software also play a
large role in the utility of the amx
module
one of the most important features of
the base code developed
for the module is the new capability of
the secondary peristaltic pump to run in
the opposite direction
of its normal operation this enables an
aspiration step to be performed with a
peristaltic pump
the revised software also gives the
ability to select new aspirate and
dispense steps which are specific to the
module
as you can see in the screenshot of the
liquid handling software
seen in the upper right of this slide
when the steps are opened either using
the onboard
computer or biotech's liquid handling
control software
a variety of rates can be chosen for
aspiration the rates range from one to
five
which corresponds to speeds of either
10 to 50 microliters per second
for dispense rates range from 1 to 8
corresponding to 10 to 160 microliters
per second
the rate chosen depends on whether 96 or
384 while spheroid plates are
incorporated
in addition to the weld geometry for
example is it a round bottom
a pyramid bottom etc a spheroid
microplate
also of importance is the makeup of the
spheroids such
as a tightly aggregated loosely
aggregated
or otherwise type of spheroid and
finally the number of cells in the
spheroid itself
the software also gives the ability to
move the two
tubes away from the spheroid in the x
y and z axis which i'll further explain
in the subsequent slides
and serves to improve the robustness and
dependability
of the aspiration and dispense steps
so now that i've introduced you to the
components of the amx module let's take
a look at how they work together
to enable the spheroid microplate media
exchanges and washes
first again if we start with aspiration
we can see in the pictures
at the right side of the slide that the
tubes are positioned
away from the spheroid in the back right
corner of the well
the tubes are also slightly elevated
from the actual well bottom
and this combination ensures that liquid
aspiration
takes place away from the spheroids
therefore when the liquid
is removed from the well using the
optimized speed 85 to 90 percent of the
total volume
is removed leaving the spheroid behind
the value programmed into the step is
also set
to be greater than the volume expected
to be removed from the well
and this accounts for any evaporation
that may have taken place
from the well and even out evens out the
volume
within each well after the dispense step
has been completed
the same process is followed whether the
wells have
a round or square configuration or
whether aspiration is taking place in
the larger wells of a 96 well plate
or the miniaturized wells of a 384 well
plate
so to help further out illustrate the
process i have a few different
video clips captured from different
angles taking place in
either 96 or 384 well plates in the
first
video seen here we're looking for more
of a top
down view at media being removed from
a 96 well round bottom spheroid plate
so i'm just going to move to the next
slide and now you will see the actual
video being played so the plates
contained
an original volume of 100 microliters of
media
and so therefore a volume of 110
microliters was set in the software
and as you can see the tubes move into
the well using
an offset in the x and y axis that
positions the tubes
away from the middle of the well to the
back right corner
and then aspiration then proceeds in a
controlled manner until the volume level
is below the bottom of the tubes
leaving the small residual volume
so then in the second video we're again
seeing aspiration
from a 96 well plate however this time
from the side of the plate to better see
the
media removal so we'll move to the next
slide
so again you can see that the tubes move
to the back corner of the well
and aspiration proceeds in a controlled
manner from
column to column since the diameter of
the wells vary from
vendor to vendor the x and y offsets can
be adjusted
accordingly as part of the optimization
process
to create a reliable and repeatable
aspiration procedure
then as i mentioned earlier aspiration
can also take place
in 3d 4-well plates so here wells are
still evacuated in a column wise
fashion with the tubes toggling
from back and forth from the odd wells
of the column first
and then to the even wells of the column
so again if we move on and start the
video
okay so in this case um a pyramid bottom
384 well plates
was incorporated and you can see
aspiration in the even rows which
places tubes 8 in row p
and then when this step is completed the
tubes move to the odd rows of the next
column
and you can see the meniscus of the
liquid moving down
the well as the media is removed
okay so then for dispensing two
different main protocols are followed
when
using 96 well spheroid plates the tubes
are again positioned at the back right
corner of the well
to avoid moving the spheroid
as liquid is dispensed back into the
well
which we see in the figure at the right
of this slide
then for three to four well plates
however due to the smaller
area of the well and the slower speed of
the dispense the tubes are positioned
directly above the spheroid
obviously not directly on top of the
spheroid but a small distance away in
the z-axis
so due to the small area of the well
though the spheroid is not displaced
away from the center when liquid is put
back
into the well and this speed of the
dispense
is again controlled depending on the
geometry of the well
and the size of the incorporated
spheroids
so again now let's take a look at what
the dispense looks like in real life
by again viewing a few video clips so
we'll start
with 96 well top-down view as before
go ahead and start that video
so again as you can see the tubes come
down into the well
directly positioned at the back left
corner of the wells
liquid is then slowly
added in a controlled manner with the
volume and speed previously optimized
for the procedure being performed
and included spheroid model
you can see here the liquid being slowly
dispensed into
column 12 of the microplate
okay and then again
now the same dispense process
into 96 wool plates viewed from the side
so here we see tip placement into
the back right corner of the well as
with aspiration
and then a smooth controlled dispense of
the liquid
into the well what's also apparent
is the consistent volume in the wells of
each column
following completion of the aspirate and
dispense procedures
then finally again we have the
3d four weld plate so we'll move on and
view that video
uh so again you can see movement of the
tubes
between the odd and even rows of the
column before moving
on to the new column and also liquid is
dispensed slowly so that even though
tubes are positioned
directly at the middle of the well as i
mentioned previously spheroids are not
displaced from the center of the well
okay
so then during development
of the hardware and the software
components
of the amx module we performed extensive
testing to ensure that each portion of
the module
could be easily optimized and then the
combination could deliver
an exchange procedure that consistently
does not remove
spheroids from the wells of the included
test plates
so in the initial set of experiments a
qualitative
validation was performed so first
hct-116
cells were dispensed in a 100 microliter
volume to the wells of a 96 well round
bottom spheroid microplate
and the cells were allowed to aggregate
for 48 hours
to form spheroids following aggregation
85 microliters was removed from the
wells either
using a hand-held multi-channel pipet
for the odd columns
or the amx module on the multi-flow fx
for the even columns
in equal volume was then dispensed back
to the wells using
again either manual or amx automated
dispensing to
odd or even columns respectively
the process was then repeated three
times and following each round of media
exchanges
bright field imaging of the plate was
performed
then in the second experiment
glioblastoma cells were dispensed to
wells
of either a 96 or 3d4 well spheroid mica
plate
and then again following aggregation the
amx module here
solely was used to perform the media
exchanges
and then here five five media exchange
cycles were performed back to back to
simulate a wash procedure
and show that the module could be used
for more than
single aspirate and dispense cycles
so in this slide we're seeing the
results from the manual
and amx exchange procedure comparison
in the screen capture at the top right
of the slide
showing the plate layout view following
a single aspirate dispense cycle
we can see that no spheroids have been
removed from the even column
where as 23 spheroids
have been removed from the odd columns
then when looking at the bottom right
image showing again the plate layout
view after
three aspirate dispense cycles we see
now that 32 spheroids
have been removed from wells where the
procedure was performed
manually while again no spheroids were
removed
from amx processed wells and also of
note if you look at well
g11 you can see that
after one media exchange cycle
the spheroid is not in the area of the
well imaged
however following the third exchange
cycle the spheroid is once again visible
this illustrates the point that i made
earlier that spheroids
even if they aren't removed from the
well can be moved out of the imaging
area by manual pipetting which still
renders any data from that well
unusable
then now if we look at the results from
the second experiment
where exchanges were performed so solely
with the amx
module you can see that all spheroids
remain
in the wells after five rounds of back
to back aspirate and dispense
cycles meaning that processes such as
washing fluorescent probes
following incubation or fixing
permeabilizing and staining
with antibodies can also be performed in
an automated fashion
also during the development process we
performed another type of visual
validation
to con confirm that spheroids were not
removed
during the exchange process so i'll move
forward and start
this video clip so in this case
as you can see here we're zooming in
from below
the plate stage containing the spheroid
microplate
and we can see the spheroid in the
middle of the well and then the two
move into the well to begin the
aspiration process
as the media is removed from the well
the sphere remains in the exact position
that it was
in before the start of the liquid
removal and does not
move even as volume levels continue to
decrease and the meniscus gets closer to
the spheroid
so again obviously confirming the
robustness of the optimized amx
aspiration step
so now thus far i've been talking about
running the system as a standalone unit
however for automated processing of
multiple plates the multiflo effects
can also be combined with either the
biostack
if endpoint processing is being
performed
or if live cell automation requiring
sterile processing
is necessary the multi-flow effects can
be combined
with the biospa eight position benchtop
uh cell incubator in either a microplate
reader
or cellular imager such as this citation
one or five
so again the picture on the upper right
would be the
multiflo effects with the amx module in
the biostack
and then the picture on the bottom right
would be the complete system
of the multi-flow fx on the left
with amx the biospa on the right and
then in this case in this position it
would be the citation
imager and then because the biospa
controls temperature and co2 or nitrogen
levels and also contains a water
pan for humidity long term 3d assay
procedures requiring media exchanges
can also be performed in an automated
fashion and i
should also point out that the the three
instruments that you're seeing
in the picture at the bottom left are
small enough
that each of these can be also
placed into a laminar flow hood
that biotech can provide
so that again a large containment system
is still not
required if you want to run all three of
these
instruments in again as i mentioned
earlier a live
cell unattended process to work with
with spheroids
so again the reason why i'm explaining
this to you now is that
the final set of quantitative
validations
that i'm going to talk about included an
automated procedure
incorporating the multiflo effects with
the mx
the biospa and the citation 5. so
here we dispensed multiple different
cell types into spheroid microplates
from a variety
of severed microplate vendors including
corning grinder and s-bio and allowed
the cells to aggregate
into spheroids and then performed a
14-day spheroid proliferation experiment
where the spheroids were dosed with a
variety of camp to these and
concentrations
at time zero and then again at regular
interval subsequent
media or media exchange or media
containing compounds
was automatically removed from the
microplate wells using the amx
aspirate cassette and then media with
fresh compound was
placed back into the wells using the
dispense cassette
individual methods were optimized
depending on the plates
and the well configurations being used
so here in this video clip we're seeing
kinetic images
captured of an uninhibited pink one
spheroid
which was tested in a 96 well spheroid
microplates
from from s bio
and i'll start this up and as you can
see
the skewered remains in the viewing
field
and continues to grow in size as
the cells continue to proliferate over
the 14 day period
as we would expect
then when we look at the plate layout
view
of all of the test spheroids at the end
of the incubation period which is shown
on the right we see that no spheroids
were lost
following multiple rounds of media
removal
and compound redosing in addition we see
that spheroids in row a
which received a 10 micromolar dose of
camtasia
proliferated the least and are the
smallest in size
and then as we go down the plates
spheroids that
uh received lower doses of camp to
thesin have proliferated to greater
extents
with the largest spheroids being at the
bottom of the plate where the cells were
exposed to little or no drug
we also see that spheroids in the same
row
are of similar size and that the wells
are clean and show no evidence of
contamination
even after being in contact with the
aspirate and dispense
pins multiple times and all these visual
observations confirm that equal volumes
and concentrations of drug are delivered
to the wells during the repeated
exchange
processes and that incorporation of the
cassettes
when autoclaved do not pose a
contamination threat
so to further confirm the results from
the spheroid proliferation test we also
went on
to quantify calculated spheroid volume
and to do this we use the gen 5 cellular
analysis software
available with the citation 5 to
automatically place object masks
around each spheroid image at every time
point collected
so i'm going to move on to that video
clip
let's start that again and here we can
see the same spirit proliferation
movie that i showed to you earlier
however in this case
you can see in yellow the object mask
that was automatically placed
by the software for each image captured
over the 14 day period
then if we plot calculated volume over
time for each of the time points
collected
from the spheroids dosed with the eight
different
camp to these and concentrations using
the three different cell models
you can see the kinetic dose response
curves shown here
and from all this data we can see that
spheroids proliferate as expected in
relation
to the concentration of the drug added
to the wells
confirming that the incorporation of the
amx module
into an automated long-term assay
procedure
provides robust and reliable data
so then before we can uh we conclude i
want to mention
that we currently have validated methods
that are available for 96 and 384
well round or u-shaped spheroid
microplates
from corning and grinder as you can see
and then for u v
and m bottom 96 well and u bottom 384
well spheroid microplates from
s bio and these methods can be either
sent to current multiflo fx customers
upon purchase of the amx module
or used for demo purposes with
prospective customers
so in conclusion as i've shown here
today the amx module
used on the multi-flow fx enables the
performance of either
single aspirate and dispensed cycles for
media exchange purposes or multiple
aspirates
and dispense cycles for endpoint washing
procedures
with a small footprint enabling the
instrument to
fit into existing laminar flow hoods and
the ability to autoclave the cassettes
sterile processing can easily be
achieved for either short-term or
long-term assays
and when coupled with additional
automation such as the biospot 8 and
citation
walk-away long-term 3-d testing
procedures can easily be achieved
so if you'd like to learn more about the
amx module i invite you to go
to the two web links provided here
the first gives information about the
product itself
and then the second is an application
note that was recently published
that gives more information also about
the validation
experiments that were performed
and with that um i again thank you for
your attention
and we'll take any questions that you
might have
great thank you brad for that terrific
presentation
um as you mentioned we're gonna now take
a look at some of the questions that
have come in
so if you haven't done so please be sure
to enter them in the chat window
we'll get to as many as we can and any
that we are unable to get to
we will follow up with offline so thank
you
okay so um uh the first one is talking
about the
the rad module um being uh
used on a different instrument such as
the eo5 or eos
el406 that module
is actually specific to the multiflo fx
but if you have the correct
configuration
of the multi-flow effects that uh that
module can
be um can be added uh at a at a later
time so that is
that is certainly possible and also
um uh then the second question
from the the same attendee
was asking about the aspiration speed
in microliters per second so if you
remember in
my previous slide earlier in the
presentation
i mentioned that the slowest speed both
for
aspiration and dispense would
be uh 10 microliters per second which in
again in a lot of the the testing that i
have performed
with uh spheroids as low as just a few
hundred
uh cells per spheroid going up to
uh spheroids you know that contain
multiple thousands
of cells um that slowest speed
uh will definitely work um for any you
know spheroid model in a round bottom
uh or pyramid bottom plate and then if
you have um uh steroids with
with a larger number of cells like like
i mentioned with you know
maybe you know a thousand two thousand
five thousand cells you certainly could
go
up to a higher rate of both um uh
aspiration and dispense because remember
larger spheroids will have
um a bigger bulk and a more of a weight
to them uh so that will allow them to
you know maintain their position in the
bottom of the well
during a slightly faster aspiration
and dispense speed
okay
so in the next question is do we need
the amx
module to change media for adherent
2d cell culture and 3d cell culture
within uh matrigel
so that's that's definitely a good
question so
if you have uh adherence um
cells the uh i also talked about that
the multi-flow effects
has a wash module and that allows you to
perform washing with a vacuum pump um
so you so you certainly could use that
for
cells that you know have a high degree
of it at adherence
to the bottom of um to the bottom of the
well or
if your spheroids or tumoroids or
organoids
are encased into
into a hydrogel such as major gel or
collagen
then you could also use the
vacuum pump obviously with the caveat
that you would need to definitely
optimize
the height of tube placement just as you
would
with the amx module but you could you
could certainly use the amx
module you know if you just wanted that
um and and not have to worry about
having both the vacuum pump and and the
amx module
amx would certainly work for uh 2d
cultured cells
or um you know any type of
3d cell model within within a hydrogel
okay so um if we
uh if we move on the next one is talking
about
potential use of the amx module
with other types of other types of plate
configurations so i can tell you
that future testing will
include work with um with 24 wells
the tube placement should allow the
um the tubes to go into the middle
of a 24 well plates and so again
either if you have uh your 3d
um you know cell models in
24 i know a lot of organoid work is
currently taking place
in lower density plates um so that is
something that we will definitely be
looking at
as far as 1536 that is a possibility
i i will just you know additional
testing will have to
uh you know uh make sure that um you
know tubes can
can consistently go down into the wells
of the 1536
well plate but i don't see why that
would um
would be a problem uh um in the future
[Music]
okay so the next question is wondering
if the biospa
or biostack would fit inside of a hood
so again um the biospa certainly as i
just mentioned a few slides ago can
certainly fit inside of a hood uh
biotech has recommended hoods that work
with the biospa
and then you know again if you want to
add the
the multiflo effects or multiflo effects
with a reader or an imager that
certainly can be achieved
um biostack i'm
that with the that has a little higher
um
uh or um uh in the z-axis
uh so i would have to that's something
that we would have to check into and and
um get back to that may not be able to
be placed
into a hood but that's something that we
could certainly um
look into and get back to you on okay
the next
one is um
uh concerning use of amx and other
non-3d applications
uh example using tissue samples in a
microwell
um i that's certainly you know any
any type of cell model um you know
tissues
may be attached to the bottom of a
microplate well
so that's certainly um would be possible
uh i will mention that one of the things
that we're we will be
working on in the future is looking into
use of the amx module with
non-attached suspension models such
as immune cells
to see if that could be used you know to
to do media exchanges during
activation procedures such as like t
cell activation
or working with nk cells but that that's
work that has not been
completed yet and more information
should be available
for that um in the in the coming
months um
[Music]
uh so in the next question it talks
about
oh how does dispense of different
concentrations of proliferating
uh compounds be achieved so again
remember
i talked about that with both of
the with with our peristaltic pump
cassettes and this is true both with
amx or with non-contact dispensing one
um one tube of the cassette
goes to one you know or one line
is specific so it goes all the way
through so
in that case you can put um one end of
the
of the tubing into uh you know again
into a
50 ml conical tube or a 1.5 mil conical
tube
and then that concentration
of the drug or you know whatever it may
be
antibody um etc would be dispensed
into um wells
of that particular row because again
that that tube
would be um would would work with all
the wells of uh
one particular row of a 96 well plate or
obviously two
rows of a 384 well plate so in that case
um
with each line going into a different
concentration
again of your test agent uh that's how
you can achieve
up to an eight point dose response uh
with the with the dispense cassette of
the amx module
um again with another question about
different
um well configurations and again this
this will
uh that testing will be coming soon but
that
certainly should be um should be able to
be
achieved
[Music]
a question about pipetting into a 384
well plate
the the speeds obviously will
differ slightly depending on the
um on the the size of the spheroids but
what i found is uh either with
a round bottom or a pyramid bottom
because
uh the the spheroid you have a smaller
uh area of the well the steroid really
stays in place
so you can um bump up the aspiration
and the dispense um speeds so that
um you know you aren't uh taking you
know an extremely long time
to uh to do the um the the meat exchange
procedure for a 384 well played so still
um a few minutes and then that procedure
should be um should be completed and
then you can either
you know obviously manually remove the
plate back to
the incubator or if it's in an automated
situation the plate would be
moved back to the biospa
the average dead volume for the
cassettes this is a
five microliter uh cassette so the dead
volume is um is around five
uh five mils i will mentioned that
the um the cassette tubing if
uh if necessary can be
cut the the length of the tubing when it
comes
from biotech is 30 inches in in length
and the reason why it's slightly longer
is that
many times the multi-flo fx is used in
um
an online uh screening type of
configuration
so that the vessel containing the liquid
is you know a certain distance away from
the actual
instrument so uh if that's not necessary
the the tubing can be cut and then
obviously
um the vessel would just be you know
placed
closer to the actual instrument so that
can
definitely cut down on the on the dead
volume that you would
uh that you would be using in addition
to the amount
that you would need for dispensing into
the plates um
the next one um
[Music]
uh i'm not quite sure about what's being
um there's a the question that um it
says what is the mtb
f for amx module i'm not quite sure what
that's referring to so if you want to re
submit your question that would be fine
so the next question is talking about
what's the accuracy of the
x y and z motors um
so they they do work in steps so at each
um uh each step refers to
a fraction of a
micrometer so in that case you know you
can change
the the placement of the tubes
in all three axes you know by by a
very small amount um so that you're not
uh you know sacrificing and having to go
up multiple
uh micrometers with uh with each step so
you should really be able to dial in
your um you know the the proper
placement of the tubes
um depending on what microplate again
whether it's
you know the three i mentioned uh
corning grinder or s bio or some other
type of um
uh microplate um
[Music]
so another question is can this system
be
used for
stem cell differential differentiation
protocols this would be a great
way to to use this
this method because obviously
differentiation protocols
um typically require uh cells
whether they're 2d or or 3d to be
in the wells for multiple weeks so
obviously
there you would need to
you know to perform multiple uh media
exchange
steps during that during that procedure
so yes this would be a great use for
stem cell differentiation procedures
another question is about transwell
plates
so again um with the um
with the positioning of the uh
of the of the tubes in the z-axis i mean
obviously you can
you know with the transwells you have a
you know kind of a either a um a single
insert
or an apical plate uh placed within a
basal lateral plate so you
they you know the the placement of the
membrane is
is up in the z-axis so obviously there
you would just
um optimize the you know the
the the movement or the the positioning
of the tubes
uh upwards in the z-axis so again that
should be
able to be used uh with um with trans
wall plates
uh have we next question is have we
worked
with flat bottom microplates actually we
have
um just recently and
you know that that procedure can be um
achieved now uh one one caveat of a flat
bottom microplate especially working
with spheroids
is that you know the spheroids can be um
uh basically you know since you don't
have the round bottom
well the the spheroids can be basically
anywhere
within that um within that well so
you know some care would have to be
taken to properly
uh position the tubes in the z-axis
so again that spheroids aren't um
aren't being removed but with the the
you know the lowest
setting the 10 microliter per
second aspirate rate that certainly
should be
able to be
to be achieved and i
just got confirmation from one of my
colleagues who's
also on the on
the the webinar that depending on the
hood this is this has to do with the
question about can the biostack
be placed into a hood so depending on
the hood configuration
uh some of our we have different um uh
plate stack uh uh that work with the
biostack
um so that again depend depending on the
configuration
a 10 or a 30 plate stack would which
obviously would not have a
a a as great of a height um would
uh would fit into a hood um
but uh the 50 plate stack obviously
which would be higher would not
would not fit into those hoods and
then
[Music]
one of the one of the last questions
is are the validated programs for
the manufacturer's specific plate types
based on different flow rates
and tip positions of the wells i mean
they they would be so obviously
different manufacturers have
the diameter of the wells
is slightly different and
also specifically for
for 384 some manufacturers have
a round bottom for 384 some have a
pyramid bottom
and again the geometry of the bottom of
the well where the
the spheroid is sitting can also
play um into the the sp uh
speeds that can be um uh that can be
used
for both aspirate and dispense but again
those are
you know we can we can certainly provide
those methods and
any um optimization of different plate
types can certainly
be easily uh carried out within you know
a very short
um you know period of time it doesn't
take a lot of
of time to um to do that
uh um type of uh um
you know type of an optimization
procedure um
and then going back to the um the
mean time between failure
i'm assuming that's potentially
how often have we seen
removal of of spheroids in the testing i
guess what i can tell you
is that once um with with all the
different plates that i've
i've mentioned during um the webinar
that once
i have the um uh
you know the the positioning of the pins
optimized i do not see
uh removal of of spheroids so obviously
you know
there's going to be a little bit of
time and care you know by the individual
user again if you are
using a different plate type but you
know with the ones that we have
validated
right now we're seeing excellent results
and um
and you know with repeated uh testing as
i you know as i mentioned
with especially with the um you know
with that
day spirit proliferation where you know
we
we had you know multiple aspirating
dispense cycles in
all the wells of 96 and 384 well plates
we
did not see spheroid removal during that
complete time
okay so it looks like that is
the um the last question and we're
getting close to the top of the hour
so i think i'm going to complete the q a
session and then
i will uh throw it back to um
to dylan but again if if anyone has
further questions
about the system or if you're interested
in in demoing it
uh please you know let's either let your
local
sales reps know or or feed a question
through me
and um you know we can pass along any
information or bring it in
for a demo so okay thank you dylan
thank you so much brad and thank you to
everybody that attended and all the
great questions
um and we hope you uh we will see you
again soon